welcome to the heavy spoilers show
i'm your host definition aka the guy who
didn't make the cut
when it came to getting a proper job and
this video were breaking down a very
interesting update in regards to the
suicide squad aircut
now if you've been living under a rock
or in a parallel universe where warner
brothers actually released the films
that they paid directors to make in the
first place
then chances are you haven't seen the
big announcement that the studio made
this week
as of 2021 the long-awaited
much-anticipated
justice league snyder cut will be making
its way to hbo max
the movie is getting a rumored 30
million dollars spent on finishing the
cgi
and having the actors record additional
dialogue it's amazing news
but it also left fans wondering if we
would get a release of the other film
that dc butchered
that is suicide squad throughout this
video we're going to be breaking down a
major tease by a t
that makes it seem like one day we will
be getting it
we'll also be discussing some of the
details that are confirmed to be in the
film
as well as its ending because of that
there will be heavy spoilers here so if
you don't anything ruined then i highly
recommend that you turn off now
make sure you subscribe to the channel
for videos like this every day and
please drop a thumbs up if you enjoy the
content
without the way thank you for clicking
this now let's get into our breakdown
of the aircut news
okay so on wednesday zack snyder did a
live stream for man of steel
which culminated in the announcement of
the snyder cut this
sent the internet into a frenzy and
youtubers like me
realized that they needed something else
to milk luckily
fans quickly started asking what was
happening with the air cut
this was further fueled by david ayer
who tweeted out a picture of the joker
everyone's favorite version of the joker
hinting at a potential release of his
intended version of suicide squad
in case you don't know the original film
was actually far different to the one we
got
i have shot it to be more in line with
batman v superman and man of steel
however after negative reactions swamped
the former of those two films
warner brothers decided to change
direction with their properties this led
to several major changes in the film
and in of course justice league which
was in production at the same time
aya didn't even get final say over the
edit of the film and this was passed
over to a company that specialized in
making movie trailers
it was all a bit weird and the film was
still received negatively
making a lot of fans wonder whether it
was even worth it
so to cut a long story short now that
warner brothers have righted the wrongs
right is that right right at the wrongs
of releasing the snyder cut
it looks like they may give the same
treatment to david ayer
now this was further teased by a tnt who
currently owns warner brothers
when a fan asked the company whether we
would be getting a release of the aircut
they replied with a tweet that said one
thing at a time
david ayer then quoted this and said
standing by
to which they replied with a holly meme
in which she smiles
so a bit a bit of tease in there you
know just a bit
don't start tweeting hashtag release the
haircut just yet but
wait there's more twitter account
fanboyclay then tweeted
this always this and then then a t
replied with a gif of everyone's
favorite suicide squad villain
enchantress
saying anything is possible all it takes
is a little magic
shut the front door so yeah whilst this
isn't a direct confirmation
for the corporation to be tweeting this
it does seem like the ball is rolling
and that they are finally giving the
fans what they want we've pretty much
all woken up in a parallel universe
known as the snyder verse
a universe where there's no need to cgi
out a mustache
and will smith is one of the greatest
comic book characters of all time
now whilst this is no confirmation
website the culture nerd posted an
article this morning that stated that
they found out from insiders that vfx
studio x studios have been commissioned
to finish the cgi
on both the snyder cut and aircut that's
uh that's a lovely coffee machine by the
way i must remember
by that and and a kindle and a new
playstation so well anyway well
this isn't complete confirmation either
and all reports like this should be
taken with a pinch of salt
it does seem like the wheels are indeed
in motion zoic have apparently been
brought on board to make adjustments to
superman's black suit
change steppenwolf back to how he was
and also revert the parademons to their
original appearance
multiple studios are working on the
project but these are the only ones that
have been tied to the aircut
fan reception has been so positive for
the snyder cut that it seems like the
aircoat would be another home run for
hbo max
they've managed to drum up so much
publicity for the platform in the last
couple of days
that it just makes sense to do it if the
snyder cut is successful
who knows this could massively change
the shape of the dc eu
and the studio may even go back to the
direction that things were originally
heading
as the fan support is definitely there
but what differences
are actually in the air cut and what can
you expect
well if you've been following ayer then
you'll see that he's teased a ton
of changes on twitter unlike the snyder
cut the air cut was
actually finished and the studio just
decided to release the one cut
by by the guys who made the original
sonic trailer i'm just kidding i don't
know if that's true
but release the original sonic cut you
cowards
as for the film itself originally the
entire ending was different
now shout out to superhero nexus for
breaking down a lot of these details
and they really paint the film in a new
light giordalito has openly spoken about
how much of his characterization was
left on the cutting room floor
and it's definitely shrouded in a lot of
mystery the film was originally a harley
and joker story
that showed a lot more of their
relationship from almost beginning to
end
it would show the toxic side of the pair
and just how much the joker manipulated
her
and had her at his every beck and call
the film was very much
similar to the style of birds of prey
tony which centered around her breaking
free of his grasp
and making it on her own the back and
forth between the two would culminate in
their relationship falling apart
as harley falls out the helicopter this
would symbolize her
finally breaking free at the end joker
would show up for the enchantress battle
with his face badly scored
as we saw in the trailers unable to
control harley any longer he would make
a deal with enchantress to become the
king of gotham
and to get her back this was confirmed
by ayer on twitter
after a user put out the following post
from what i've heard
after joker's helicopter crash he made a
deal with enchantress where he'd take
holly and be the king of gotham
and was present in the third act since
ss was mainly a holy
and dead shot film the temptation would
have been greater
the fight then happened but unlike the
theatrical release the movie ended with
steppenwolf arriving on earth
and we actually saw people kidnapped by
parademons which set up the justice
league
it was revealed that steppenwolf was
actually controlling enchantress through
her mother box
and the people that she turned actually
changed into parademons
steppenwolf wanted to invade the planet
and take things over
now judging by how this tweet is
answered it's even possible that
steppenwolf may have been a villain for
the third act
after all he was teased in batman v
superman depending on what version you
watch
and thus die hard dc fans would know who
he was at the very least
so not only was the movie setting up the
next one to come it was also showing the
depths of steppenwolf's
reach according to superhero nexus
steppenwolf would be seeing if he could
beat those who he viewed as earth's best
team
and this pushed for the justice league
to be formed he was also meant to take
over the power plant which we saw appear
in justice league
so yeah tons and tons of things that
really built the dc universe as a whole
it definitely sounds a lot more
interesting to me and
after the snyder cut release it feels
like anything is possible
aya has slowly been building a lot of
hype surrounding his movie
and fans are clamoring for more of the
director's original vision to finally be
brought to the screen
as mentioned earlier if the snyder cut
is successful then i can definitely see
hbo making an announcement to say that
the movie will be coming to their new
streaming platform
as it just makes sense to portray the
way that the dc eu should have been if
they're going with a snyder cut
at the moment it just feels like an
amazing time to be a dc
fan there's just so many good things
happening at the moment
and you really get the feeling that they
might actually give marvel a run for
their money at this point
as someone who loves both companies i
really can't wait to see what happens
and yet 2021 is shaping up to be an
amazing year for films
uh can't be worse than this one at least
so excited good times
the best of times it really puts a smile
on my face
and i'm trying not to overload the
channel with snyder cut stuff at the
moment but when the news is this good
it's hard not to now obviously i'd love
to hear your thoughts on this
announcement
and if you're hyped for it or not
comment below and let us know and if you
enjoyed this video then please drop a
thumbs up
and make sure you check out our full
breakdown of the snyder cut which is
going to be linked at the end
we go through everything we know is in
the movie from start to finish
so it's definitely worth checking out if
you want to know more if you want to
support the channel from as little as 99
cents a month then please click the join
button below
we massively appreciate it and as a
thank you you get access to content
early
if you want to come chat just after the
show either follow us at heavyspoilers
or click the discord link in the
description below
every month we give away free movies to
people are subscribed to the channel
and this month you can win the marvel
phase 3 part 2 box set and all you have
to do is comment on a video and make
sure you sub with notifications on
the more videos you comment on the more
you have a chance of winning so make
sure you get involved
the win is going to be chosen at random
on the 15th of june and the set will be
shipped out from then to forget the
prize
so best of luck to everyone who takes
part
this is a channel for people who are
super into superheroes
so if that's the kind of thing you like
hit subscribe thank you for taking the
time to watch this
i've been definition you've been the
best and i'll see you next time
take care peace
[Music]
you